a clip from a Law and Order episode has
just gone viral this is Law and Order
has been on the air I think for 150
years at this point I think Law and
Order predates the invention of the
television Law and Order has gotten
consistently more and more woke as the
culture has gotten more and more woke uh
there's a scene that's gone viral of a
woman being interviewed by cops and
she's been raped she was raped by a
black man but she doesn't want to
prosecute him because of her white
privilege but Natalie Jay Watson raped
you you think I
forgot how could I this entire trial has
been an exercise in reminding me and
this is your chance to do something
about it I am going to believe me
because I can I can afford therapy I
have that luxury and maybe one
day I'll be okay
but if that
teenager goes to
prison he may not
be
ever I don't want
that Natalie
wait everyone's making fun of this clip
I don't know why they're making fun of
this clip that seems very accurate to me
that is exactly how liberal white women
think
yes I think it was Robert Frost who said
a liberal is a man who can't take his
own side in a quarrel absolutely that's
how a lot of liberal white women in New
York City would think yes I've been
victimized but but the the man who
victimized me is black and I'm white and
so I must have done something wrong I
must have been asking for it even if I
was and I've got so much privilege we
can never punish anyone certainly not if
that person is black you can't punish
them they're great great great great
great great great great great great
great great great great great
grandparents might have been slaves or
something so we can't punish criminals
if if we send that man to
prison
he he what he what he might be reformed
that's that's the thing that might
happen of course the the woman the
character is wrong in what you but I
actually think that Law and Order
episode is pretty accurate on how white
liberals talk about race and Justice and
crime and all that stuff of
course now in real life what would
happen is this woman would say no don't
prosecute this man or probably the Das
or someone say no don't prosecute him
he's black he lives in the inner city he
can't we can never hold anyone
accountable for Crime there and so he
would be released and then he would
immediately rape someone again and he'd
probably do it like 10 or 20 more times
and then maybe he'd go to prison for
about 5 minutes but then he'd get out on
parole and he go do it a bunch more
times too that's what would really
happen so it wouldn't help
anyone if if he were punished there's a
chance he might be reformed I know
people who' have gone to prison for more
serious crimes than that actually and
who have been reformed and lived good
lives so you can do it it's called a
correctional facility the point is to
correct you but uh what what we're told
now by the libs is the complete opposite
we're told now by the libs is that uh if
you held responsible for your crimes uh
you will
it will destroy your life and if you're
not held responsible you'll somehow
magically clean up of course of course
that is not the case but that is an
accurate reflection of the culture good
job good job Laur and order you got it
right a Rhode Island School Board has
just made an audacious claim that would
make all of our founding fathers roll
over in their graves which is that
parents should not be notified of their
CH children's sexual behavior in
schools I don't think parents should be
notified
simply
because Society assumes that every child
has a well meaning family culture that
is accepting of this sometimes the worst
thing you can do is involve a parent in
some of these issues based on their own
beliefs and their own culture and that
pause right
there sometimes the worst thing you can
do is involve a parent in some of these
decision ISS based on that parent own
belief and
culture so she's speaking very vaguely
here she doesn't quite Express that
she's talking about lgbtq issues until a
little bit later but that view is very
very popular among the Liberals and it's
at least an admission that there's a
difference between the culture of the
public school culture meaning like to
cultivate like how your kid is going to
be raised there's a difference between
that culture and the culture that many
parents have at home there's a a big
difference between the beliefs being
pushed in public schools Where Your
Children Are Being indoctrinated by
these beliefs and the beliefs held by
those kids families there's a big
difference here and when when a conflict
arises they're going to go with their
own beliefs and they're going to
override the beliefs of parents keep
going will cause that student to commit
suicide and there it is put pause right
there
again this is the second thing we hear
especially in the debate we hear if you
don't side with the Liberals if you
don't suppress the conservative beliefs
the traditional beliefs your kid's going
to kill himself the the worst kind of
emotional manipulation I've ever heard
but it's effective even me I'm I'm
pretty immune to this God forbid I ever
heard this from a from a teacher or
something I don't think I would for
reasons that we'll get to in just a
moment but if I did I that would scare
the Daylights out of me I would have to
take a say am I totally wrong should I
totally cave on my beliefs I don't
that's you you've threatened me with the
scary iest thing I can
imagine and that's what they do they say
yes you got to side with us you can't
ever side with the parents if you side
with the parents you're going to kill a
kid keep going if you tell a student
who's trusted you who has come out to
say that I'm
lesbian and you now go back and tell the
parent that child has no faith in that
school system ever again and will never
come forward with any
information and his second
recommendation or the third
recommendation pause this is a little
subtle point but she says and if that
student says She's a Lesbian but that's
not really what we're talking about here
is it when we talk about lgbtq Elemento
P we're not talking about the the
16-year-old girl who you know kisses a
girl at a party after truth and dare and
thinks she's a lesbian for three days no
that's the most anod version of it which
is why this is what this manipulative
liberal woman is doing she won't say
what we're really talking about which is
um homosexual men who engage in Far
riskier behaviors than lesbians and we
want to talk about the real thing that
everyone's talking about which
[Music]
is when you send your kids to a public
school today you are signing that kid up
for the possibility of having his
genitals chopped off simple as not being
hyperbolic not not not being provocative
just for the sake of doing
so that's what they think that's what
the liberal schools think that's what
the broader liberal culture thinks
that's what the federal government
thinks is that that's just who they are
if he's a boy and he thinks he's a girl
that's just who he is and the schools
and the government institutions have
have a a right and a responsibility to
keep that information from the parents
to hide this information from the
parents and to encourage the kids to
harm themselves that's what they're all
saying out in public you can't say you
weren't warned and we all saw this
during Co too that's what it means today
maybe you went to public school I went
to public school doesn't mean what it
used to mean that's what it means today
they're telling you that risk when they
tell you who they are you got to believe
them that was a good clip huh
now ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael nlls YouTube channel see you
next time